[Musik]
in Kiew schrillen wieder einmal die
Alarmglocken doch nun nicht nur wegen
drohender russischer Angriffe was
diesmal Alarm schlägt ist die
Staatskasse visualpolitik Zuschauer
haben uns darauf hingewiesen die
ukrainische Regierung steht vor der
Pleite ihr geht das Geld aus was nicht
nur erhebliche wirtschaftliche sondern
auch militärische Folgen haben kann der
Titel dieses Videos wirst du manchen der
die aktuelle Nachrichtenlage über den
Kriegsverlauf mit verfolgt überrascht
haben denn sieht es momentan nicht eher
danach aus dass der russischen
Stellungen kollabieren nun ja wie ihr am
Ende dieses Videos genau verstehen
werdet sind militärische Erfolge an der
Front das eine aber Sie können sich
schnell wieder in Luft auflösen wenn auf
einmal die Heimatfront Weg sagt dann
kommt die Niederlage scheinbar plötzlich
und unerwartet von hinten einen
Durchstoß gleich und glaubt mir diese
Gefahr ist durchaus real und derzeit
auch hochgradig akut worüber wir in
diesem Video sprechen werden ist
sozusagen die Kehrseite der Kriegsfront
auch sie ist unverzichtbar findet aber
in den Medien kaum Beachtung die Ukraine
kämpft nicht nur gegen Russland sondern
auch mit einer großen wirtschaftsfinanz
und Energiekrise und deren Auswirkungen
können richtig drastisch werden denn all
die Widerstandskraft und die bisherigen
Erfolge der ukrainischen Streitkräfte
könnten zunichte gemacht werden wenn das
Land und die Gesellschaft wirtschaftlich
zusammenbricht aber wie ernst ist die
Ukraine vom Ruin bedroht wie hoch ist
der durch die russische Invasion
verursachte Schaden genau wer finanziert
letztlich die Kriegsanstrengungen und
die vielleicht wichtigste Frage von
allen wie wird sich das alles auf dem
Schlachtfeld aus na interessiert euch
das genauso wie uns dann hört jetzt gut
zu
[Applaus]
[Musik]
an der Front hat sich die Lage für die
Ukraine deutlich verbessert gute sechs
Monate nach Beginn ihrer Invasion kommen
die Russen praktisch nicht mehr voran
sind im Gegenteil massiv in die
Defensive geraten erst gab es
erfolgreiche ukrainische Angriffe gegen
militärische Ziele auf der Krim und
inzwischen laufen an verschiedenen
Frontabschnitten erfolgreiche gegen
offensiven Putins Truppen werden im
Süden schrittweise zurückgedrängt
10.09 22 Russland gibt aufgrund des
Zusammenbruchs seiner Frontlinien die
hauptbastionen im Nordosten der Ukraine
auf nachdem die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte die Versorgungswege gekappt
und das Gebiet in einem Blitz Vorstoß
eingekreist hatten während der letzten
Monate war den Russen eigentlich nur
noch der Vorteil ihrer zahlenmäßig
überlegenen aber unpräzisen Artillerie
geblieben die der ukrainischen Armee und
den Städten heftig zugesetzt hat
Russland nutzte seine enorme Power um
alles auszulöschen was ich ihnen in den
Weg stellte um so ihrer Infanterie das
Vorankommen zu erleichtern nur half es
nichts der Vormarsch der putinischen
Armee ist trotzdem fast vollständig zum
Stillstand gekommen denn wie zuvor war
der Luftwaffe und den Panzertruppen ist
es den Streitkräften der Ukraine auch
hier gelungen die quantitative Übermacht
der Russen durch einen asymmetrischen
technisch überlegenen Konter zur
neutralisieren diese Tendenz entspricht
dem gesamten Kriegsverlauf egal was und
wie viel Putin in die Schlacht wird die
Ukraine schafft es immer wieder die
massive Schlagkraft seiner Armee durch
intelligentere und modernere Taktiken
unschädlich zu machen waren es in den
ersten beiden Fällen intelligente und
agile manpads und Panzerfäuste welche
russische Piloten und panzerkommandeure
das Fürchten lehrten lag der Schlüssel
zum Erfolg diesmal in der Verkrüppelung
der russischen Logistik durch die vom
Besten gelieferten hochpräzisen
artilleriesysteme mit welchen die
Ukraine durch chirurgische präzise
Angriffe die russischen Munition sepos
zerstörten und
wohlgemerkt das alles in Kombination mit
deutlich überlegenen kampfleid und
Kommunikationssystem mit denen der West
die Ukraine ausgerüstet hat aufgrund
ihrer mangelhaften präzisionen benötigen
die russischen Geschütze eine
unglaublich riesige Menge Animation um
überhaupt mal irgendetwas zu treffen und
um ausreichend Munition an die Frauen zu
bringen braucht es eine leistungsfähig
und ausgeklügelte Logistik nun war
Logistik noch nie die Stärke der Russen
man erinnere sich nur an den riesigen
Konvoi mit dem sie die Belagerung Kiews
durchführen wollten der aber nichts
anderes war als ein peinlicher 64 km
langer Stau es lag also von Anfang an
sehr nahe das nachschubwesen als größte
russische Achillesferse anzugreifen
natürlich kannten die Russen diese
Gefahr auch von Anfang an und versuchten
daher alles um die Lieferung und den
Einsatz der westlichen
hochpräsentationsartillerie zu
verhindern
[Musik]
da wurde sogar mit Atomkrieg gedroht
falls der Westen die Systeme liefere tja
aber auch dieser blöff hat nicht gezogen
die Heimat und panzerhau Wissen 2000
haben ihren Zweck bereits erfüllt und
zum Atomkrieg ist es trotzdem nicht
gekommen noch mal Schwein gehabt dabei
scheint die Ukraine noch nicht mal ein
einziges dieser Systeme verloren zu
haben denn auf den Lieferlisten der
letzten Tage tauchen keine Ersatzsysteme
auf sondern nur jede Menge frische
präzisionsmunition und währenddessen
behauptet der kriemel mehr heimatssystem
vernichtet zu haben als überhaupt
geliefert wurden tja schon irgendwie
merkwürdig das ganze auf der anderen
Seite scheint die Strategie des Pentagon
jedoch auch darin zu bestehen genauso
viele Waffen und Unterstützung
anti-ukraine zu liefern damit die Russen
nicht zu sehr abgeschreckt werden nur so
werden die russischen Streitkräfte in
ausreichender Zahl aus der Reserve
gelockt um sie dann in erheblich
größerem Umfang aufzureiben und
auszubluten als wenn sie zurückhaltend
vorgehen würden um der Gegenoffensive
auch zu begegnen mussten die Russen ihre
besten Verbände Osten und dem Donbass in
den Süden verlegen wo sie bis hinter den
jepper gelockt wurden und nun nach der
Zerstörung aller Brücken ihrer
Einkesselung und aufreibung preisgegeben
sind doch diese einigermaßen gut
ausgebildeten und ausgerüsteten
Einheiten fehlten anschließend in Norden
so dass die Ukraine dort ohne größeren
Widerstand über 2.000 Quadratkilometer
besetzte Territorium zurückerobern und
wichtige logistische Knotenpunkte wie
zum Beispiel ist jung einnehmen konnte
dadurch wird für die Russen auch die
Nachschub Situation in don-bass
außerordentlich kritisch auch dort
könnten sie große Probleme bekommen
vorrückende Ukraine aufzuhalten zumal
die massenweise in Gefangenschaft
geratenen russischen Soldaten berichten
sie wären nur für reinen offensivkampf
mit schwerer Artillerie und
Luftunterstützung ausgebildet und
vorbereitet worden und würden über
keinerlei taktische Fähigkeiten verfügen
um ihre Stellungen auch verteidigen zu
können
[Musik]
[Applaus]
scheinbar hatte die russische
Militärführung bei der Vorbereitung
ihres Angriffskrieges nie damit
gerechnet irgendwann auch in die
Defensive geraten zu können was nun zur
Folge hat dass ihre Armee den breiten
ukrainischen Gegenangriff zum größten
Teil Schutz und hilflos ausgeliefert ist
die Front ist mehr als 1300 Kilometer
lang und die Russen haben 200 bis 250 im
defensivkampf nur unzureichend
ausgebildetes Soldaten das reicht bei
weitem nicht aus um eine ernsthafte
gestaffelte Verteidigung aufzubauen
geschweige denn parallel noch offensiven
zu führen die russischen Kräfte haben
sich vollkommen überdehnt und verfügen
kaum noch über Reserven den stehen
mittlerweile und eine Millionen Mann auf
ukrainischer Seite gegenüber jedoch
immer noch nicht über ausreichend
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge schwere Waffen
aufklärungssysteme und
Kommunikationsmittel verfügen um diese
Masse an drucken die notwendige
Mobilität und Koordination zu verleihen
würde die Ukraine schon heute über
genügend Ausrüstung für diese ar
einfügen wäre sie klar die überlegenere
macht und könnte den Krieg sehr zügig
beenden
[Musik]
das Ziel scheint also die nachhaltig und
dauerhafte Schwächung Russlands als
Militär macht in geopolitischen Maßstab
zu sein und schon jetzt kursiert der
Flotte Spruch die 12 stärkste Armee der
Welt sei heute nur noch die
zweitstärkste in der Ukraine aber im
Ernst aus dem militärischen Lage wird
eines ersichtlich der widerstandsgeister
Ukraine und der Einsatz westlicher
Waffen haben der ukrainischen Armee
reichlich neue Kampfkraft verlieren und
die Resultate lassen sich wirklich sehen
umfangreichste territorialverschiebungen
seit mehr als fünf Monaten die Ukrainer
Rücken im Nordosten immer weiter vor in
einer offenbar von langer Hand
vorbereiteten Aktionen griffen sie
russische Stellungen in der Provinz Karl
kiff an und erzielten vom Dienstag bis
Freitag verblüffend rasche
Geländegewinne aber wie gesagt all das
bezieht sich auf dem militärische
Frontlage in diesem Video wollen wir uns
daher mit einem anderen Schlachtfeld
beschäftigen nennen wir es die
wirtschaftsfront
der von Russland angezettelte Krieg hat
verheerende Folgen sowohl vor Ort als
auch für die gesamte ukrainische
Wirtschaft viele Fabriken wurden
zerstört die Infrastruktur ist schwer
beschädigt und viele Unternehmen mussten
schließen so hat der Krieg nach
verschiedenen Erhebungen etwa die Hälfte
aller Jobs im Lande vernichtet entweder
weil es die Arbeitsplätze gar nicht mehr
gibt oder bei Löhne und Arbeitszeiten
stark geschrumpft sind trotz der
Einberufungen zum Militär betrug im Juni
2022 die Arbeitslosenquote bereits über
35% schaut euch mal diese Karte an
im Sommer 2022 waren etwas mehr als 20%
des Staatsgebiets der Ukraine von
Russland besetzt oder schlichtweg
Kriegsgebiet das sind die Regionen die
ihr hier dunkelblau seht vor dem Krieg
erwirtschafteten diese Territorien etwa
20% des ukrainischen
Bruttoinlandsprodukts dort lebten etwa
28% der Gesamtbevölkerung
[Musik]
aber das ist längst nicht alles zwar
gibt es stärker oder weniger stark
betroffene Gebiete aber Russland hat
Infrastruktur Fabriken und Städte im
ganzen Land bombardiert
[Musik]
zum Beispiel wurden durch russische
Raketen alle großen Ölraffinerien
zerstört oder schwer beschädigt und noch
ein Beispiel einige der größten
Industrieanlagen des Landes befanden
sich just in mariopol heute sind sie ein
Trümmerfeld das zu dem von den Russen
besetzt ist auch das Atomkraftwerk
saporegja das größte Europas ist
Russisch besetzt es liegt direkt an der
Frontlinie was nicht nur ein enormes
Sicherheitsrisiko darstellt nein es muss
wegen der Kämpfe auch immer wieder vom
Netz genommen werden was die
Energieversorgung des Landes in Gefahr
bringt insgesamt wird allein der von
Russland in den ersten sechs
Kriegsmonaten verursachte Schaden auf
Hunderte von Milliarden Dollar geschätzt
eine riesiges Summe für eines der
ärmsten Länder Europas und zu dieser
enormen Zahl müssen wir zig Milliarden
hinzu addieren die noch durch die
Schließung von Fabriken und Firmen
verloren gehen sowie all die Kosten die
es braucht um das Land wieder auf die
Beine zu stellen ganz zu schweigen vom
Verlust an Menschenleben im unsäglichen
Leid und dem Massenexodus von
Flüchtlingen was also sind die
ökonomischen Folgen all dieser brutalen
Zerstörung nun nichts weniger als der
Kollaps der ukrainischen Währung eine
riesiges Loch im Staatshaushalt eine
galoppierende Inflation und eine
Wirtschaft im freien Fall betrachtet man
die Löhne so ist die Ukraine nun wieder
das eindeutig ernste Land ganz Europas
[Musik]
aber inwieweit gefährdet diese Krise nun
die gesamte Zukunft der Ukraine wie groß
ist das Ausmaß der wirtschaftlichen
Zerstörung dieses Land erleidet und was
genau dürfte das für den Krieg bedeuten
ja das alles sehen wir uns jetzt genau
an
die finanzielle Seite des Krieges
russland hat etwa ein Fünftel der
Ukraine besetzt aber auf die eine oder
andere Weise betrifft der Krieg das
ganze Land konkretes Beispiel gefällig
laut einer Umfrage die Anfang August 22
durchgeführt wurde haben 54% der Ukraine
Angehörige Familienmitglieder oder
Freunde die gegen die Invasoren kämpfen
keine Frage der Widerstand gegen
Russland ist zu einer Quelle von
Nationalstolz und Zusammenhalt geworden
doch Kriege sind nicht nur schmerzhaft
und zerstörerisch sie sind auch
furchtbar teuer permanent Kampfeinsätze
durchzuführen das ist nicht gerade
billig vor allem wenn die Kämpfe das
wirtschaftliche Gefüge des Landes direkt
betreffen nach Angaben der ukrainischen
Behörden wird die Wirtschaftsleistung im
Jahr 2022 um mehr als 33% einbrechen
wobei die Weltbank sogar von
dramatischen 45% Rückgang spricht und es
könnte noch schlimmer kommen so sind z.B
praktisch alle Investitionsprojekte zum
Stillstand gekommen und die wichtigsten
Banken der Ukraine sehen sich mit
Ausfallraten von gut 30% der Kredite
konfrontiert sollte diese Situation
längere Zeit anhalten
Ihnen dass die Luft ab mit anderen
Worten sie können direkt in den Bankrott
getrieben werden und wenn eine
Wirtschaft in diesem Ausmaß kollabiert
tun das natürlich auch die
Staatseinnahmen
in der Ukraine sind die Steuereinnahmen
im Monat Juni real umfasst 50% gegenüber
dem Vorjahr eingebrochen aber dennoch
der Krieg muss finanziert werden während
also die Einnahmen um die Hälfte
geschrumpft sind stiegen die staatlichen
Ausgaben und schätzungsweise mehr als
60%. das Ergebnis eine riesige brutale
Lücke in den öffentlichen Haushalten
denn obwohl die ukrainische Regierung
alles weggekürzt hat was nicht unbedingt
notwendig ist schafft sie ist derzeit
gerade einmal 30% aller Staatsausgaben
durch Steuern zu finanzieren in
konkreten Zahlen sprechen wir also von
einem Defizit von etwa 5 Milliarden Euro
pro Monat ein enormer Betrag für ein
Land dessen BIP für das ganze Jahr 21
bei knapp unter 200 Milliarden Euro lag
und wenn wir den aktuellen Eindruck der
Wirtschaftstätigkeit berücksichtigen
könnten das erwartete Defizit 2022
vielleicht 40 Prozent des BIP
übersteigen da stellt sich die Frage wie
um alles in der Welt kann eine solche
gigantische Haushaltslücke finanziert
werden
vergesst nicht dass wir nicht nur über
Dinge wie Renten und Gehaltszahlungen
für Ärzte sprechen was unter den
gegebenen Umständen ja alles sehr
wichtig ist sondern auch über
Militärausgaben um den Krieg aufrecht
erhalten zu können muss die Ukraine
dieses gigantische Defizit finanzieren
die Frage ist nur wie sie das überhaupt
machen soll und ich weiß schon was
manche von euch denken ganz easy
Schulden machen wie alle anderen na ja
aber das geht nur bedingt überlegt mal
wird Ihr bereit euer Geld in den Kauf
von Staatsschulden eines Landes zu
stecken das am Rande des Bankrott steht
zu einem Fünftel vom Feind besetzt ist
und aktiv gegen Russland Krieg führt
eben
[Musik]
deshalb musste die Regierung selenski
nicht nur Schulden machen sondern auch
zu anderen Maßnahmen greifen zum
Beispiel hat die Zentralbank wie
verrückt geldgedruckt um die
Staatsausgaben zu finanzieren das
Problem ist dass dies nicht nur die
Inflation Einheit sondern auch den Wert
der Hilfen ja der ukrainischen Währung
unter Druck setzt das wiederum zwingt
die Zentralbank ihre Devisenreserven zu
verbrauchen damit die Landeswährung
nicht völlig zusammenbricht im Sommer
dieses Jahres verbrannte die ukrainische
Zentralbank im Durchschnitt jede Woche
eine Milliarde Dollar in ausländischen
Währungen bei diesen Tempo könnte das
Land ein paar Monaten ohne einen
einzigen Dollar da stehen deshalb ist es
für die Ukraine so wichtig ihre
außenhandelskanäle wieder zu öffnen dazu
gehört natürlich auch der Verkauf von
Getreide ich bin mir sicher ihr habt
davon in den Medien gehört allerdings
dürfte dieser Wirtschaftszweig im besten
Falle gerade mal eine Milliarde Dollar
pro Monat einbringen und das auch nur
bis die gesamte Ernte verkauft ist also
ein Betrag der viel zu gering ist um
alle Lecks zu stopfen die das Land
derzeit hat und so ergeben sich dann
Nachrichten gibt diese 21 Juli 2022 die
Ukraine wertet die herivia um 25%
gegenüber dem US-Dollar ab Ende Juli
beschloss die Ukraine ihre Währung um
25% abzuwerten um die revenir zu
stabilisieren indem sie Exporte billiger
und Importe teurer machte damit sollte
der Abfluss von Devisen aus dem Land
verringert werden
aber klar das alles ist nicht mehr als
ein notbehelft weder kann die
Zentralbank weiterhin umfassen die
Regierung finanzieren noch kann das Land
weiterhin seine Dollars und Euros
verbrennen und natürlich sind sich die
Ukraine dieser Tatsachen sehr wohl
bewusst die Situation ist so heikel dass
die Regierung alle öffentlichen
Unternehmen im Land aufgefordert hat die
Begleichung ihrer Schulden aufzuschieben
auch wenn sie das Geld dazu haben
sollten
das Ziel ist es den Abfluss von Devisen
um jeden Preis zu stoppen das hat auch
die Regierung selbst getan indem sie mit
ihren hauptgläubigern vereinbart hat
alle Zahlungen für die ukrainischen
Staatsschulden um ein Jahr aufzuschieben
und als ob das noch nicht genug wäre ein
weiteres Problem für das Land ist dass
die überall in Europa der Winter vor der
Tür steht die Ukraine verfügt derzeit
über die geringsten Gasvorräte in ganz
Europa zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme dieses
Videos hatte sie gerade einmal 28% ihrer
Speicherkapazitäten gefüllt das ist
völlig unzureichend um den ukrainischen
Winter zu überstehen der knackig kalt
werden kann zum Vergleich die Speicher
der EU-Länder sind nun zu fast drei und
80% voll Berechnungen des nationalen
ukrainischen Gasversorgers besagen dass
das Land mindestens 5 Milliarden
Kubikmeter Gas kaufen muss bei dem
derzeitigen extrem hohen Gaspreisen in
Europa würde das über 10 Milliarden
Dollar kosten
und nein selbst das wäre nicht das Ende
der Energie sorgen die Ukraine wird auch
erhebliche Mittel aufwenden müssen um
das von den Russen schwer beschädigte
Stromnetz am Laufen zu halten das geht
sowohl für die Kraftwerke als auch für
die Leitungen und Umspannwerke selbst
und all das wird die Rechnungen
natürlich noch weiter in die Höhe
treiben denn selbstverständlich kann ein
Land ohne Energie nicht funktionieren
und auch nicht kämpfen
[Musik]
wohin man also schaut die
wirtschaftliche Lage der Ukraine ist
kritisch auch wenn sich einige Dinge im
Vergleich zu den ersten Tagen der
Invasion verbessert haben ja die meisten
Unternehmen des Landes haben den Betrieb
wieder aufgenommen die Versorgung mit
Benzin Diesel und anderen Kraftstoffen
ist halbwegs wiederhergestellt hat
täglich mehr als 300 LKWs die Grenze von
westenhell überqueren das Land hat auch
begonnen Strom an die Europäische Union
zu verkaufen die Abschaffung von Zöllen
und verschiedenen behördlichen Auflagen
durch die Verbündeten Länder trägt dazu
beide Exporte wieder anzukurbeln
außerdem hat der Widerstand der Armee
dazu geführt dass die Ernte zum Großteil
eingebracht werden kann doch trotz all
dem machen der Einbruch des BIP die
Schließung großer Fabriken das wachsende
Handelsdefizit und vor allem dass
gigantische Loch in den öffentlichen
Haushalten die Lage außerordentlich
kritisch lasst uns also zur der
zentralen Frage zurückkehren die wir
vorhin schon gestellt haben wie um alles
in der Welt will die Ukraine all ihre
Rechnungen bezahlen und wen wundert
genau hier kommen die westlichen
Verbündeten wieder ins Spiel wie erkläre
ich euch jetzt sofort
das Überleben der Ukraine
bislang hat die ukrainische Regierung
viele unterschiedliche Maßnahmen
ergriffen um die Lage zu stabilisieren
sie führte zum Beispiel strenge
Kapitalverkehrskontrollen ein Griff in
den Wechselkurs ein kürzte viele
Ausgaben garantierte Bankeinlagen
schafft einige Steuern ab oder änderte
sie erhöhte die Zinsen und so weiter und
so fort doch wie wir gesehen haben ist
die Situation so Vertrags dass die
Ukraine selbst nur wenig tun kann und
genau hier kommt die internationale
Gemeinschaft ins Spiel liebe
visualpolitikzuschauer es erreicht nicht
aus dass die USA die Europäische Union
Großbritannien und andere Verbündete
militärische Ausrüstung an die Ukraine
liefern denn wenn diese Alliierten
wollen dass das Land mit seinem
erbitterten Widerstand gegen Russland
Erfolg hat müssten sie sich auch mit der
Kehrseite des Krieges auseinandersetzen
und wisst ihr was das ist genau das was
sie zumindest gegenwärtig auch tun werft
mal einen Blick auf diese Grafik die
Regierung der Ukraine deckt knapp ein
Drittel aller öffentlichen Ausgaben
durch Steuern einen ähnlichen Betrag
erhält sich von der Zentralbank und den
Rest bringen die Verbündeten auf diese
Hilfe ist bereits zur bei weitem
wichtigsten Quelle zur Finanzierung des
Haushaltsdefizits geworden und es wird
erwartet dass sie ihn im kommenden
Monaten noch zunehmen wird damit Kiew
aufhören kann Geld zu drucken
[Musik]
insgesamt erhielt die ukrainische
Regierung zwischen dem 24 Februar 22 dem
Tag an dem die Invasion begann und
Anfang August mehr als 12 Milliarden
Dollar von den Vereinigten Staaten der
EU Deutschland Japan Kanada und anderen
Verbündeten also 12 Milliarden in Form
von Zuschüssen Spenden und Darlehen zu
sehr sehr günstigen Konditionen um die
Ausgaben der silence die Regierung zur
finanzieren
[Musik]
und nicht nur das dieselben Verbündeten
haben sich verpflichtet den nächsten
Monaten weitere 20 Milliarden Dollar
auszuzahlen nur um den Haushalt der
Regierung zu stützen wenn wir zu diesem
Betrag die humanitäre Hilfe und die
gesamte Militärhilfe hinzu zählen
beläuft sich die Summe die die
Verbündeten bisher zugesagt haben auf
über 80 Milliarden Dollar und wie ihr
dieser Grafik entnehmen könnt entfällt
der mit Abstand größte Betrag auf die US
Open
das ist eine Menge einer beträchtliche
Stange Geld besprechen hier von einer
historischen Mobilisierung von
Ressourcen um den Aggressor in diesem
Fall Russland für die Folgen seines
Handelns auf dem Schlachtfeld büßen zu
lassen schließlich steht nicht nur die
Ukraine auf dem Spiel in diesem Krieg
geht es um die Fähigkeit freier Länder
sich gegen Erpressung und Bedrohung wie
der durch Putins Tyrannei zur Wehr zu
setzen
der Kampf der Ukraine ist unser Kampf
mortenbützkow dänischer
Verteidigungsminister aber leider ist
das noch nicht genug so war die Ukraine
die EU erst kürzlich um weitere 12
Milliarden Euro
der Krieg in der Ukraine wird
wahrscheinlich so bald nicht enden und
wenn die westlichen Demokratien wirklich
wollen das ist der Ukraine gelingt den
Aggressor abzuwehren müssen sie viel
größere Anstrengungen unternehmen sie
müssen noch mehr militärische technische
und finanzielle Ressourcen bereitstellen
und vor allem die Auszahlungen
beschleunigen das heißt Sie müssen das
Geld schneller freigeben aber zugleich
auch die Garantie bekommen dass das Geld
auch dort ankommt wo es gebraucht wird
wir haben es euch schon in vielen Videos
gesagt die Ukraine waren nie dafür
bekannt ein erstklassiger Rechtsstaat
oder das transparenteste Land der Welt
zu sein aber so oder so muss das Geld
fließen und es muss schneller fließen
vor allem weil die wirtschaftliche Lage
in der Ukraine absolut kritisch ist und
das meine Freunde ist die Kehrseite des
Krieges eine zweite Front einer
ebenfalls eine Menge geleistet wird auch
wenn sie selten im Fernsehen auftaucht
zudem deuten Meldungen wie diese auf
etwas anderes Thema
die europäischen Mächte haben der
Ukraine im Juli keine neuen
militärischen Zusagen gemacht die
militärische Unterstützung Europas für
die Ukraine ist nach Angaben des Kieler
Instituts für Weltwirtschaft seit April
rückläufig das Engagement der USA
Großbritanniens und der meisten
osteuropäischen Länder scheint fest zu
stehen aber in anderen Ländern wie
Deutschland und Frankreich gibt es
politische Kräfte die Opportunismus und
defätismuspredigen und auch die
Standhaftigkeit der Menschen in die
Solidarität der Freiheitlichen
Wertegemeinschaft zu untergraben
versuchen es handelt sich zumeist um
dieselben gestalten die uns zu Beginn
des Krieges und auch im weiteren Verlauf
immer wieder weiß machen wollten
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine würden
nur den Krieg verlängern denn sie hätte
gegen die mächtige russische Armee
sowieso keine Chance ich kann jedem nur
raten merkt euch ihre Namen gut denn sie
werden auch in Zukunft versuchen durch
falsche Prognosen und scheinheilige
friedensabfälle unsere Resilienz gegen
totalitäre Kräfte zu sabotieren und
unsere gesellschaftlichen Werte zu
untergraben mit den militärischen Siegen
der Ukraine sind diese nützlichen
Idioten Putins zwar bereits heute
widerlegt was jedoch nicht davon
abbringt ihre Laie weiter zu spinnen und
sich hierzu auf ein neues Thema
einzuschießen
[Musik]
sie nutzen vor allem die
energiepreiskrise und liegt damit
verbundene wirtschaftliche Misere vieler
Menschen für eine perfide Täter Opfer
Umkehr damit der Eindruck entsteht nicht
Putin seine Schuldige am ganzen Leid
sondern irgendwie auch die Ukraine und
ihre Unterstützer Zaudern könnte sich
aber gerade jetzt als großer Fehler
erweisen und den Krieg unnötig in die
Länge ziehen je schneller Russland mit
seiner Invasion scheitert desto eher
kann in Europa wieder Frieden und
Stabilität einkehren auch in Washington
ist man sich im Klaren darüber und das
in diesen Krieg viel mehr auf dem Spiel
steht als die ukrainische Souveränität
über den don-bas oder den Süden des
Landes auf dem Spiel steht neben der
Weltkonjunktur auch die Vormachtstellung
der freien Welt und es geht auch darum
andere Diktaturen wie China pink zu
zeigen was man niemals tun sollte zum
Beispiel in Taiwan darüber hinaus hat
Russland nicht nur viele der wichtigsten
Industriegebiete der Ukraine erobert
sondern auch einen sehr großen Teil der
natürlichen Ressourcen des Landes was in
Wiederaufbau sehr schwierig gestalten
könnte
einigen schätzungen zufolge könnte
Russland bereits über 60% der
Kohlevorkommen des Landes 42 Prozent der
erstvorkommen und ein Drittel aller
Vorkommen an seltenen Erden und anderen
wichtigen Mineralien wie Lithium an sich
gerissen haben nicht unerheblich sind
auch die bisher unerschlossenen
Erdgasvorkommen der Ukraine immerhin die
zweitgrößten in Europa nach denen
Norwegens wir haben darüber in unserem
letzten Ukraine Video berichtet dass ich
euch in der Beschreibung natürlich
verlinken werde das ukrainische Erdgas
befindet sich zum größten Teil jedoch
ausgerechnet unter dem Don Bass und den
Hoheitsgewässern der Krim so dass viele
glauben Putins Invasion der Ukraine sei
bereits seit 2014 dadurch motiviert
einen wichtigen Konkurrenten im
Gasgeschäft mit Europa schachmatt zu
setzen wie würde die Ukraine ohne die
russischen Interventionen heute wohl
wirtschaftlich da stehen und dabei
möchte man sich gar nicht ausmalen wie
die Zukunft der Ukraine aussehen würde
wenn Russland nicht eindeutig besiegt
wird
die Ukraine würde nicht nur einen
Großteil ihres Territoriums und ihre
Ressourcen verlieren sondern wäre auch
ständig der Bedrohung eines neuen
russischen Angriffs ausgesetzt niemand
von klarem Verstand und kein
Privatunternehmen würde in der Rest
Ukraine investieren wenn dies zu einem
eingefrorenen Konflikt wird Jakob Kirche
Grad Forscher am Petersen Institute
International Economics in Washington
und vergesst nicht dass er bisher nur
darüber gesprochen haben was die Ukraine
braucht um sich im Kampf gegen die
Russen auf den Beinen zu halten denn die
Wahrheit ist dass das Land mittel und
langfristig viel viel mehr Geld brauchen
wird nach bisherigen Schätzungen geht es
um Hunderte von Milliarden Dollar um die
ukrainische Wirtschaft die Industrie die
Städte und Infrastruktur wieder intakt
zu setzen dieser Krieg ist wahrlich
verheerend tja all das mag euch als
gigantische Menge Geld erscheinen und
das ist es auch wir müssen jedoch
bedenken dass das kumulierte BIP der
Verbündeten Länder 50 Billionen Dollar
übersteigt mit anderen Worten sie haben
mehr als genug Muskeln um die ganze
Rechnung zu stemmen so gesehen ist der
Preis den wir zahlen müssen um Putin zu
besiegen und er zu zeigen das ist besser
ist mit freien Ländern verbündet zu sein
durchaus akzeptabel
[Musik]
bei der dauerhaften Stabilisierung
Osteuropas und als wichtiger Pfeiler der
9 europäischen Sicherheitsarchitektur
nach dem Krieg wird das mächtige
Wiederaufbauprogramm ein neuer
Marshallplan eine maßgebliche Rolle
spielen wir haben euch diesen Plan wie
auch seine mögliche Finanzierung aus
komplizierten russischen Mitteln bereits
vor kurzem in einem Video vorgestellt
der ukrainische Justizminister Deniz
majuska will Kriegsentschädigungen aus
Russland von mindestens 300 Milliarden
Dollar durchsetzen diese Summe
entspräche den Guthaben der russischen
Nationalbank die in den G7 Staaten
eingefroren sind klar ist dass der Krieg
in der Ukraine weit über die Ukraine
hinausgeht das wird auch in Russland
stets betont die Ukraine ist militärisch
und finanziell vom Besten abhängig und
wenn sie es jetzt schon geschafft hat
die russische Kriegsmaschinerie
aufzuhalten dann vor allem dank ihres
hartnäckigen Widerstands aber auch dank
des Engagements ihrer westlichen
Verbündeten aber die Lage ist wie wir
gesehen haben immer noch kritisch es
wird noch mehr Geld benötigt und zwar
schnell wenn das nicht geschieht könnte
die ukrainische Wirtschaft komplett
kollabieren was ist prakt unmöglich
machen würde den militärischen
Widerstand aufrecht zu erhalten ohne
Produktion ohne Geld ohne Nachschub und
mit einer galoppierenden Krise kann das
Land nur wenig ausrichten und falls euch
unserer Meinung interessiert wir von
visualpolitik sind der Ansicht die
Ukraine muss um jeden Preis unterstützt
werden dies ist eine dieser historischen
Momente in denen sich die freie Welt
gegen Tyrannei behaupten muss aber was
meint ihr in welchem Umfang und wie
lange sollten die Verbündeten die
ukrainischen Kriegsanstrengungen
finanzieren bis Russland zu einem
Waffenstillstand bereit ist bis die
Invasoren hinter die Grenzen vor die 24
Februar zurückgedrängt sind oder gar bis
in der die von 2013 wie immer sind wir
auf eure angeregte Diskussion zu diesem
Thema schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe
dass euch dieses Video gefallen hat und
ihr vielleicht auch etwas dabei gelernt
habt falls ja gib uns bitte ein Like
heißt mit euren Freunden vergessen das
Abo mit Glöckchen und keines unserer
Videos mehr zu verpassen natürlich
freuen wir uns auch jederzeit über eine
Spende von euch mit uns hält dieses
Projekt weiterzuführen den PayPal Link
dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]